will be removed from office with
immediate effect
now if the prime minister wins with less
than 50 percent voting against him he
stays in the job and has the right to
remain there unchallenged for one year
so how are the numbers looking so far
well this morning sky news understands
that around 12 of 20 mps who are elected
in 2019 and are part of the so-called
pork pie plot have already submitted
letters
we know seven other mps have already
publicly called for boris johnson to go
although many more letters could
officially have gone in
well let's talk to a panel of mps to
test the mood as the prime minister
prepares to take questions in parliament
we're joined now by sarah jones the
shadow minister for policing who is the
labour mp for croydon central pauline
latham the conservative mp for mid
derbyshire and alan smythe the snp's
foreign affairs spokesman who's the mp
for sterling um sarah jones to you first
of all we did see what appeared to be
genuine contrition on the face of the
prime minister yesterday um do you
believe him that he is
full of remorse for what happened
i think the prime minister has
completely lost authority and he's
putting to shame the office of prime
minister he cannot claim surely surely
nobody would believe that he can claim
that he didn't know uh what he was
walking into and then didn't recognize
it when he saw it i think this
government is
is tired he's mired in this party
sleeves and and they are not operating
uh with the best interests of the people
at heart they are not dealing with this
awful rise in inflation and cost of
living crisis where labor has policies
we have plans to reduce energy bills to
get the economy moving uh to learn to
live well with covid all of these issues
the government are not pushing forward
any kind of agenda they are just trapped
in this um uh
defending of a man who seems unable to
tell the truth
and that that is the point isn't it
pauline latham that
whatever you think of boris johnson from
inside the conservative party whether
you think he should stay or go
these discussions are nothing but a
distraction
there are a distraction there are some
really important things out there that
actually everybody needs to be focusing
on what russia is doing on inflation
there's
really serious issues
and all this is just
um
a distraction from the real issues that
we do need to tackle because
we don't know what's going to happen
with russia we need to be focused on
that in the ukraine
there's just so many things that we need
to be thinking about and this
really
although i i'm completely
understand how the people feel out there
they are very angry and frustrated when
they follow the rules and it looks as
though those in downing street did not
follow the rules but actually it in many
ways it's out of date and it's
it's happened yes it's happened and
should anybody be seen to have lied to
the commons then clearly they have to go
but really what we need to be focusing
on is bigger things much bigger than
anything else that's happening
have you sent a letter to sir graeme
brady suggesting a vote of no confidence
in the prime minister
no because we don't know what sue gray's
um
report will say so i'm i want to see
that before i pass any judgment and it
is for individual mps to make that
decision
and i wouldn't tell you if i sent it in
anyway but i mean as we haven't come to
the conclusion of the process it's only
another few days and we will know so i
think i'm i'm just suspending my
judgment at the moment because i want to
really focus on other things that are
happening in
the country
and the world
thanks very much let's bring in alan
smith from the s p in sterling and
you've got an opposition day motion next
week the s p have um
will you use that to force a vote of no
confidence in the prime minister if
enough letters don't go in between now
and then
well our position is clear and we think
boris johnson should go and uh frankly i
think there's hermit monks in caves in
tibet who knows when not if he goes
that's obvious and it's not just about
the recent revolutions it's about the
culture of his government the way he's
undermined truth and integrity in public
life the way he's been caught out being
fast and loose with the truth over the
northern ireland protocol there's going
to be a border in the irish sea then
there wasn't then there was and all of
that stuff so our opposition day it's
presently we're looking to be talking
about the cost of living because that's
a crisis facing millions of people up
and down the country but events may well
change and we'll keep our powder dry on
that but we're clear that we we think it
is when not if we should go same as a
referendum on scottish independence is
when not if but the sooner he goes the
sooner uh then uk and scottish politics
will be the better for it and i have to
say fair play to the scottish
conservatives in the hollywood
parliament that they've unanimously
called for him to resign and i think he
should really follow their lead yes it
hasn't done a great deal for relations
between the conservatives in westminster
and in scotland has it the last week or
so um let's go back to sarah jones for
labor in croydon central and what do you
think kierstarma is going to push the
prime minister on today will it be on
the parties or will it instead be the
cost of living we've seen inflation
rising to figures that we haven't seen
since 1992 today
well i don't know what he's going to ask
but we are in crisis and clearly the
prime minister isn't operating uh with
the interests of of the people at heart
whether you're talking about foreign
affairs whether you're talking about uh
the cost of living uh whether you're
talking about covid and how we learn to
live well with that and there are a
whole raft of really serious problems
that this government has completely
failed to address in many cases they've
exacerbated by 10 years of poor
governing um and and i suspect um you
know the country now are he's waiting to
hear from the prime minister the truth
about what he actually did and said and
knew and saw on those multiple occasions
that parties seem to have occurred and
they want to know what is going to be
done about the problems that they are
facing people are facing huge energy
increases in bills uh their
real term wages are going down we have
new tax rises coming in uh april with
national insurance it's not too late for
the government to fix some of those
problems but at the moment it's only
labor that has a plan conservatives are
just talking to themselves
pauline latham do you think boris
johnson will be prime minister at the
next election
well that's a long long time away and as
we say a week's long time important i
don't know
um he may decide he's had enough and
he'll go but i don't know i'm not privy
to his thoughts but i have to say the
what the opposition doing are not really
doing their job they're not scrutinizing
government in the same way what they're
doing is just fixating on one issue and
i do think that we need to be looking at
other issues
i think i think both sarah jones and
alan smith had something to say about
this allen did just point out didn't he
they're not going to be using
necessarily their opposition day motion
uh to force a vote to know confidence
they're they're instead going to
potentially look at cost of living so
is that is that a fair criticism pauline
really
if if he um
did a vote of no confidence they would
lose it um boris would win it so they
will be wasting their time with an
opposition day motion i mean they should
do something that is important to the
country not just as part of political
because just being part of political
isn't what the public want they actually
want to hear what people are really
saying and they need to be putting the
questions to the government to to be
scrutinizing government policy that's
what opposition does but they don't do
it at the moment they're just fixated on
one subject and they're asking what
we're doing that's exactly what we're
doing we're talking about how we would
reduce energy bills by 200 pounds for um
most people and another 600 pounds for
those who really need it we're talking
about how we learn to live well with
covid and make sure we've got the
resources and the plans in place these
are important issues of the day that
people care about the government is not
talking about these issues it's only the
labour party that's talking about them
yes you say that you i want to live well
with covet but you want to just go
further and more when it's not been
necessary the prime minister has been
proved right over covet it's not a case
of
just buttoning that down we've seen now
scotland coming out of that because it
hasn't worked and actually
not true it's simply not true we have
support
okay it's going to be difficult because
you're all going to be talking over each
other so let me be in charge and bring
in alan smith to respond to that alan um
the the way that nicola sturgeon has
handled it according to pauline latham
has been shown to be wrong your thoughts
well that's demonstrable nonsense
the scottish government has taken a
cautious approach on a lot of this stuff
and there's a lot of data still to come
out in this and the very second we think
it's safe to relax restrictions we've
shown that we we do and we are and we
will so what we've done we've taken a
different approach on some matters over
covert to
the uk to england
and i'd absolutely defend that record
and we'll have the inquiry as well but
the people of scotland are comfortable
with how the scottish government has
dealt with this that's why we just won
an election and i can see why pauline
would want to talk about lots of other
issues but the reason why we're talking
about so many of these in crisis is
because the people at the top of the uk
government have been demonstrably asleep
at the wheel and focused on other things
so i want this tory psycho drama to get
out of scotland's government which is
why i want to see an independent
scotland but meantime the idea that the
opposition's fixated on the tory party
the only people fixated in the tory
party of the tory party themselves
what of what pauline says that that you
won't bring a vote or no confidence
because you'll lose it
on that to be fair i actually would
probably agree with her and that's why
we'll keep our powder dry at the moment
we're focusing our debate on the coastal
living crisis but we'll keep our powder
dry on that and we'll make a decision on
that in due course
okay
there is the prime minister boris
johnson let's listen
[Music]
are you going to resign prime minister
pretty inevitable that he would face
those questions
[Applause]
the prime minister now making that short
journey
from downing street
onto whitehall down into parliament
square and then on into
the house of commons
he has a great deal of work to do to
persuade many conservative mps that he
deserves their backing we will leave our
mp's panel there sarah jones from labour
pauline latham from the conservative
party and alan smith from the snp thank
you all very much uh for giving us your
thoughts
in advance of prime minister's questions
and as the prime minister makes his way
down to the house of commons uh let's
bring in some uh other people who've got
an interest in what is happening there
today um we've got a public panel we're
going to talk to
tiffany jones from winchester her dad
died from covert 19 in december last
year the same day as the alleged downing
street christmas party in a moment we're
also going to talk to
karen a psychiatric nurse in manchester
who worked through the pandemic and was
fined thousands of pounds for organizing
a protest over nhs pay
we're also going to talk to a chef from
liverpool and there he is paul askew
from the art school restaurant and in
the middle karen weissman and uh first
guest is tiffany jones who very sadly
lost her dad uh three of you all thank
you so much for joining us um
tiffany first of all what did you make
of the prime minister's interview
yesterday do you think he is genuinely
remorseful
i don't think he knows how to be sorry i
think the only thing he's sorry about is
the fact that he's been caught out
that's what he's sorry about he's not
sorry about the thousands of lives and
the people that have been fined frankly
unnecessarily because if he can have a
party why can't everybody else
he's sorry he was caught
what is there anything i mean you
obviously don't don't like him um is
there anything he can do or say today
that would change your mind that would
make you think actually this is somebody
who who perhaps acknowledges that
they've made errors
but that they are now going to change
and that they're not going to do the
right thing
i think
we've had now what is nearly two years
of this and there isn't much that he can
say or do at this point the kindest
thing he could do
is step down
let somebody else
sort this mess out he is a liar and he
is unable and unfit for his office
very unparliamentary language there
tiffany um karen reisman a psychiatric
nurse and also a union representative um
you were fired you were fine sorry for
holding an event
during the lockdown period tell us what
happened
the government announced that they
wanted health workers to get a one
percent pay rise after a year of
fighting govid a year of putting their
lives on the line a year of watching
their colleagues die a year of people
being disabled a year of being
overwhelmed and exhausted beyond belief
and in the middle of a second wave where
people were having to do it all over
again
and
you know they clapped us they'd said
that they respected us and then they
offered people one percent and we knew
as health workers that that was going to
drive lots and lots of health workers
out of the system who just couldn't take
any more the fact that nothing was going
to change it was bad before covid and in
covet it was even worse and to be given
a below inflation kick in the teeth for
the second year running people were
appalled and we felt it necessary to
organize sorry to sorry to butt in on
you paul we'll come to you in a moment
in the meantime our political editor
beth ruby has some breaking news there
yeah we have some breaking news uh that
a conservative mp christian wakeford one
of the 29 intake has just affected to
the labour party
uh kierstarma uh have ju has just put
these words out he says i would like to
welcome christian wakeford to the labour
party he's always put the people of bury
south fast as christian said the
policies of the conservative government
to do nothing to help the people of bury
south and indeed are only making the
struggles they face on a daily basis was
he says labour are the only ones who
have put forward a plan to help people
through the tory cost of living crisis
i'm determined to build a new britain
and i'm delighted that christian has
decided to join us in this
endeavor so just to be clear the
conservative mp elected in 2019 for
barry south christian
wakeford has just defected to the labour
party minutes before the prime minister
faces his party in the country at prime
minister's questions well clearly
interesting timing isn't it and and one
wonders what impact that will have on
boris johnson and the fact that he
always seems to be a little bit delayed
coming out of number 10 there i wonder
if that information was being relayed to
him will there be a by-election now what
happens no he's defected to the labour
party so he will stand
as a labour mp but it's quite
astonishing for the conservative party
that someone elected in that wave
of seats falling
from later seats the red wool falling
towards boris johnson in 2019 that he
has decided to actually cross the floor
of the house and join the labour party
that really is quite something that is a
body blow to boris johnson and i i
actually as a political editor and quite
shocked uh that that announcement has
come it was rumored this morning uh my
colleague rob powell was picking up some
rumors about possible defections but
that someone has actually done that and
done that before the sue grey report has
come out that the prime minister has
asked everyone to wait for is an
indication really that those 29 and
2019ers many of those mps now think that
boris johnson is an electoral liability
to them that while he helped win those
seats and turn them conservative blue in
2019 that they are just not confident
that he can be the person that will win
those seats again in the next general
election they're worried for their jobs
christian wakeford completely
disillusioned clearly
but also we know that there are a number
of the other 2019ers
now preparing to put letters in to try
to force a confidence vote in boris
johnson and somebody doing something
like this effecting the other side do
you think that that will prompt more
people to put letters in well that's
that's the big question well i think the
first question is are there going to be
more defections that's the obvious first
question um this is obviously very live
so we will begin to hit the phones on
that
and then the second question is as you
said is
politics is a confidence game and over
the past 48 hours
it does feel like the ball is now
teetering and boris johnson has been
trying to shore up support but it is
bleeding
away and there is a growing view and a
view that is
cementing really
that he might not be able to get out of
this and he might not be the person to
lead the conservatives into the next
general election and certainly for an
already very anxious febrile party the
site of a new conservative mp one of
those who came in on that 80-seat
majority that boris johnson won but just
over two years ago crossing the floor of
the house to join labour he clearly
thinks that that is where his political
fortunes now lie that he cannot sit in
on the conservative benches it will be
absolutely devastating to the prime
minister let's see what happens next
well let's see beth thanks very much for
now we'll be getting your reaction
throughout the the rest of the time
around prime minister's questions let's
just return though to our people's panel
who are just telling us their stories
before prime minister's question starts
we haven't had a chance yet to talk to
paul askew um works in the hospitality
sector runs the art school restaurant um
paul for you
how was covert and how difficult was it
for you to comply with the regulations
well i think it's been well documented
that uh hospitality had a real kicking
uh during the last 18 months two years
or so you know we spent thousands of
pounds uh and time and effort and blood
sweat and tears to make our restaurants
bars and hotels covered safe uh and
followed everything to the letter of the
law and and in our opinion went above
and beyond and created the most safe
environments that we could have ever
done
um and it all revolves around uh you
know following a plan following the
rules and we believe we've done that and
of course
now we're not out of this yet we're
still facing incredible difficulty with
staffing crisis supply chain
and we need strong leadership and of
course
if these things have happened then it's
no different than any other person in
the world they need to
be prosecuted if they have to face fines
just like anybody else who broke the
rules during the lockdown and it for me
it's not about politics it's about
what's right and what's wrong um and we
very much have done things correctly and
we'd like to see a leadership that can
can help us recover now
what about those in the government who
will say it looks like that plan b
regulations are going to be relaxed
later today potentially we'll find out
after prime minister's questions our
country is opening up faster than many
other countries in the rest of the world
and economically
we are now in a good place and that that
is because of boris johnson what would
you say to that
well i i think you know plan b has
worked you know whether we all agree
with the timing of things and the way it
was treated over christmas certainly
that created huge issues for the
hospitality industry you know we had a
massive sort of lockdown by stealth with
cancellations of big bookings and groups
it sort of happened without uh the
decree of the government anyway
so the management of that period was
incredibly difficult but but you know
you have to say
the economy is starting to recover we
are seeing businesses
starting to breathe again and look
forward and and be slightly more
optimistic so you have to give this a
measured view in in the in the bigger
picture
let's go back to karen weissman uh uh
psychiatric nurse karen we cut you off
in your prime there for that breaking
news but you were telling us how
how you were fined for holding an event
that you very much tried to ensure was
within the rules
what then went through your mind when
you heard about the allegations of
parties at downing street
i just couldn't really believe that
there is so much evidence
that shows that they not for any serious
reason but
to party to socialize on number of
occasions they have broken rules that
the rest of us stuck to
that
people made huge sacrifices over the
last sort of nearly two years and to
find that the people who are enforcing
those rules on other people and not
keeping them themselves i think is
absolutely infuriating i got fined ten
thousand pounds which it took me an
enormous amount of effort and cost
through a barrister in order to get them
to finally admit that that fine was
unlawful but to be honest why did i have
to go through that and why is the prime
minister and his civil servants and the
police i mean they must have cameras
inside number 10 that that have got the
evidence why are we in the position
where those people think that they can
carry on um and that they can carry on
with the mess that they've made of covid
um and with the hypocrisy of one rule
for us and no rules for them
tiff jones uh you lost your dad colin
and one of the things that you want to
do is
create a memorial day for victims of
covert 19. and there's been so much talk
over the last few weeks about politics
and parties do you fear that those
who've been lost
are perhaps being forgotten
every time another party
gets made light off it feels like a kick
to the stomach and people like my dad
and the 175 thousand other people are
being swept under the carpet because
it's covered it's going to be over soon
so let's just forget about it
i will never
forget this i lost my dad quite frankly
to watch something that should have been
preventable if you'd shut down sooner
and done things right and not partied
maybe my dad would still be here but
he's not
okay tiffany jones uh from winchester uh
karen riceman uh from manchester and
paul askew from liverpool thank you all
so much for giving us the kind of
thoughts that are going through your
head just in advance of prime minister's
questions and we'll leave that there and
return to our political editor beth
rigby has more breaking news beth you've
got christian wakeford's statement yeah
i've only just got it so i will
literally read it because it's only just
been sent to me this is what christian
wakeford has told the prime minister
over his decision to resign he says
i'm writing to inform you of my decision
to resign from the conservative party
and apply to join the labour party from
today i'll be sitting as a labour mp for
bury south because i've reached the
conclusion that the best interests of my
constituents are served by the programme
put forward by kirsten and his
party he goes on to say he cares
passionately about the people of barry
south and he's concluded that the
policies of the conservative government
you lead are doing nothing to help the
people of my constituency and indeed are
only making the struggles they face on a
daily basis worse he goes on to say
britain needs a government focused on
tackling the cost of living crisis he
then says it needs a government that
upholds the highest standards of
integrity and probity in public life and
sadly both you and the conservative
party as a whole have shown themselves
incapable of offering the leadership and
government this country deserves he goes
on this is christian wakefield the mp
for bury south who's just defected to
the labour party he says being elected
as mp for bury south was the proudest
day of my life i care passionately about
the area and will always be grateful to
those who supported me
and he says i have wrestled with my
conscience for many months and you will
know that i have made my policy
misgivings clear on occasions in private
sometimes in public i can no longer
support a government that has shown
itself consistently out of touch with
the hard-working people of very south
and then he says my decision is much
more
than about your leadership and the
disgraceful way you have conducted
yourself in recent weeks however i don't
believe all politicians are the same and
i do believe in the power of politics
and so does kierstama he has shown that
integrity in the way he has led the
party on issues
that said and he concludes changes can
only be delivered by labour government
with kierstarma wow that is that is
quite something isn't it yeah
disgraceful the way that the things the
prime minister has conducted himself
that the government needs to uphold the
highest standards of probity and
integrity and that the government is not
doing it and it seems that jane i know
i've literally just read that myself but
just my quick take on that there's two
things going on there it's about the
probity of the government and the
integrity he's very clear on that he's
obviously completely fed up with boris
johnson but also with the wider
conservative party because he doesn't
think that they are upholding values
that he
ascribes to and and believes many of his
constituents do so there's a there's a
personality issue with boris johnson and
the way he leads his government but he
also talks and this is very interesting
about the government not doing what it
said it would which was tackling the
cost of living crisis
but we always need here from the prime
minister prime minister's questions
i now call wendy chamberlain yeah
question one mr speaker prime minister
question one uh mr speaker i will
shortly be updating the house on this
country's fantastic progress in tackling
kovid 19 including our booster program
enabling us to ease plan b measures and
restore the ancient liberties of this
country mr speaker i know that the whole
house will be delighted that her majesty
the queen
has given permission for a special medal
to be awarded to all those who deployed
to kabul
operation pitting saw our service men
and women deliver the largest british
evacuation since the second world war
the whole country can be immensely proud
of their service
mr speaker this morning i had meetings
with ministerial colleagues and others
in addition to my duties in his house i
will have further such meetings later
today
wendy chen thank you mr speaker last
year we were told by the prime minister
there were no downing street parties
then it turned out there were parties
but we were assured that no rules were
broken
last week we heard the rules may have
been broken but that he thought it was a
work event and now yesterday from the
man who wrote the rules it was well
nobody told me what those rules were
mr speaker five weeks ago the people of
north shropshire were clear and the
people of northeast fife are being clear
to me now no matter the excuse there is
no excuse for taking the british people
for fools will the prime minister agree
it's now time for him to
[Applause]
uh resign mr speaker but what i can tell
her is that i as i said to the house
last week uh i i i apologize sincerely
for
any misjudgments that were made but she
must contain her impatience mr speaker
and wait for the inquiry next week
before she draws any of the conclusions
that she's just asserted
[Music]
thank you mr speaker
latest evidence and research shows that
the uk is the most attractive country in
the world
amongst um young people
in across the g20
amid intense soft power competition from
other countries including china can the
prime minister assure me
and other members of the all british
party all-party group
sorry british council all-party group
that the government will meet the
british council's funding requirements
to ensure it doesn't have to close any
more offices overseas and to ensure that
it commits all its energy to retaining
our top spot
[Music]
mr speaker i i entirely share my right
honourable friends enthusiasm for the
british council which is a wonderful
institution
that we all love and that's why we're
providing through the fcdo 189 million
pounds of funding uh this year a 27
increase mr speaker in spite of all the
difficulties this country is facing 27
percent of the increase uh on the
previous financial year we've also
provided a loan facility of up to 145
million pounds to support all the
wonderful work that the british council
does
welcome to the leader of the opposition
kia starbuck
thank you mr speaker can i start by
warmly welcoming
can i start
here listen to the prime minister
can i just say
i expect people to listen to the prime
minister i certainly don't want the
leader of the opposition shouted down
you might not like the day but this is
the day that we've
got islam
mr speaker i'm not bothered i assumed it
was directed over here
um
can i start by warmly welcoming the
honourable member for very south
and for the parliamentary labour party
mr speaker like so many people up and
down the country he has concluded that
the prime minister the conservative
party have shown themselves incapable of
offering the leadership and government
this country deserves whereas the labour
party stands ready to provide an
alternative government that the country
can be proud of
mr speaker the labour party has changed
and so has the conservative party
he and anyone else who wants to build a
new britain built on decency security
prosperity and respect is welcoming my
labour party
every week the prime minister offers
absurd and frankly unbelievable defenses
to the downing street parties and each
week it unravels
[Applause]
i've been elected the chair i don't need
to be told though to conduct the
business so if somebody wants to do some
direction i'll start directing them out
of the chain but yes
mr speaker i see the very noise i'm sure
the chief whip has told her to bring
their own booze
[Applause]
let's try and get on with questions it's
going to be a long day if not here
mr speaker first he said there were no
parties then the video landed blowing
that defense out the water
next he said he was sicker than furious
when he found out about the parties
until it turned out that he himself was
at the downing street garden party
then last week last week he said he
didn't realize he was at a party
and
surprise surprise no one believed him
so this week he's got a new defense
nobody warned me that it was against the
rules
that's it
nobody told him
[Applause]
since the prime minister wrote the walls
why on earth does he think this new
defense is going to work for him
thank you mr speaker well he talks about
uh the rules and let me let me repeat
what i said to uh the honorable lady
across the aisle uh earlier on of course
of course mr speaker we must wait for
the uh we must wait for the outcome of
the inquiry but i i i i renew what i've
said and mr speaker but when it comes to
when it comes to his view club nobody
believes what you said
can we have a little less i want to this
prime minister like i wanted to leave
the opposition i want the same courts
from both sides prime minister
yeah
well mr speaker if we'd listen to the
right honourable gentleman about covid
restrictions which is the substance of
his question and then then mr speaker we
would still be uh we would have been in
lockdown after july
if we listen to if this is the truth if
we listen to the labor front bench in
the run-up to christmas and new year mr
speaker we would have stayed in uh
restrictions with huge damage to the
economy and it's because of the it's
because of the judgments that i've taken
that we have taken uh in dining street
that we now have the fastest growing
economy in the g7 and gd gdp mr speaker
now back up above three pandemic levels
and as for barry's south mississippi as
for as for berry
let me say let me say to the let me say
to the right gentlemen
mr speaker by all you might say the
right honourable gentleman the
conservative party uh won a very south
for the first time in generations under
this prime minister with an agenda of
uniting uniting and leveling up and
delivering for the people of berry south
and mr speaker we will win again in very
south at the next election
[Applause]
luke
it's important i hear i want to hear
both sides and i don't want this
continuous chant because if we do
there'll be less people on these benches
and the same on the other side i expect
both sides to be heard with courtesy
here
barry south is now a labor seat prime
minister
[Applause]
did somebody want me to apologize
no somebody shouted apologize i hope it
wasn't aimed at me
and so we'll also have less from that
corner
thank you mr speaker not only did he
write the rules but some of his staff
say they did warn him about attending
the party on the 20th of may 2020.
now i've heard the prime minister's very
carefully crafted response to that
accusation
it's almost
sounds like a lawyer wrote it
so i'll be equally careful with my
question
when did the prime minister first become
aware that any of his staff had concerns
about the 20th of may party
mr speaker i i'm i'm grateful to write
about
repeating the question that he's uh that
he's already we we have uh answered
mr speaker uh that it is for the inquiry
to to come forward uh with an
explanation of what happened and i'm
afraid he simply he simply must wait but
he asked about my staff mr speaker he
asked he asked about uh my staff and
what my staff are doing what the and
what they uh have told me and i can tell
him mr speaker that they have taken
decisions throughout this pandemic uh
that that he has that he has opposed to
open up in in july mr speaker as i've
said to mount the fastest vaccine
rollout in in europe
and mr speaker to double the speed of
the booster rollout with the result that
we have the most open economy in europe
mr speaker and we have and we have more
people in employment and more employees
on the payroll now than there were
before the pandemic began that is what
my staff have been working on in downing
street uh mr speaker and i'm proud of
them
here
so mr speaker apparently sue gray is
going to tell the prime minister when he
first became aware that his staff had
concerns about the may 20th
the prime minister's account gets more
extraordinary with each version of his
defense if the prime minister's new
defense were true
it requires him to suggest that his
staff are not being truthful when they
say they warned him about the party
it requires the prime minister to expect
us to believe that whilst every other
person who was invited on the 20th of
may to the party was told it was a
social occasion he alone was told it was
a work meeting
it also requires us
requires the prime minister
to ask us to accept that as it as he
waded through the empty bottles and
platters of sandwiches he didn't realize
it was a party
does the prime minister realize how
ridiculous that sounds
[Applause]
mr speaker uh i've said what i've said
about uh the events in number 10 uh he
will have to he will have to wait uh for
the he'll have to wait through and and
mr speaker i think i think you know he
asks for uh for further clarification i
think lots of people who are interested
i say this entirely in parsley mystery
lots of people are interested in the
exact legal justification uh from the
learning learning uh leader of the
opposition uh prefer the picture of him
drinking a pint of beer or a bottle of
beer
i mean
perhaps he could tell the house about
that in a minute in a minute mr speaker
but what i can't what i can what i can
tell the house is that uh throughout the
pandemic people in across government
have been working flat out to protect
the british public uh with with huge
quantities of pbe so we can now make 80
in this country with the biggest and
most generous furlough scheme virtually
anywhere in the world and the fastest
and by the way mr speaker if we listen
to them if we listen to them we would
have stayed in the european medicines
agency and we would never have been able
to deliver the vaccine rollout at the
speed that we did
here
mr speaker if the prime minister the
only accusation he faces that he once
had a beer with the takeaway then
operation save big dog is in deeper
trouble than i thought
a prime minister misleads parliament
should they resign
[Applause]
so mr speaker let's be absolutely clear
the right honourable gentleman is
continuing to ask a series of questions
which he knows will be fully addressed
by the inquiry he is wasting he is
wasting this house this time he's
wasting the people's time mr speaker he
continues to be completely irrelevant mr
speaker we have an inquiry we have an
inquiry mr speaker and i and i'm not
going to anticipate that inquiry any
further what i what i can tell him is
that it is because of the judgments that
were taken in downing street because of
the willingness of the british people uh
to put trust by the way mr speaker in
those judgments and to come to come to
come forward in huge numbers to get
vaccinated which people did and i thank
them for it for the bottom of my heart
people did that
because they listened to our messages mr
speaker and it was a result of that that
we now have the fastest growing economy
in the g7 and una youth unemployment
which he ought to care about youth
unemployment at a record low mr speaker
[Applause]
i know it's not going well prime
minister but look on the bright side at
least the staff at number 10 know how to
pack a suitcase
mr speaker
last year
last year her majesty the queen sat
alone
when she marked the passing of the man
she'd been married to for 73 years
she followed the rules of the country
that she leads
on the eve of that funeral
a suitcase was filled with booze and
wheeled into downing street a dj played
and staff parted late into the night
the prime minister has been forced to
hand an apology to her majesty the queen
isn't he ashamed that he didn't had in
his resignation at the same
time mr speaker i i understand why the
uh right honourable gentleman continues
to
politicize sorry
we normally would not and quite rightly
mention the royal thing
[Applause]
we don't get into discussions on the
royal family
well in that case mr speaker i must ask
the right honourable gentleman to
withdraw it
i've dealt i've dealt with it
here's stomach
[Applause]
we don't want to go through that again
i'll make the decisions
the answer is the next question i'm
going back to kirsten to ask his final
question
[Applause]
thank you mr speaker whilst the prime
minister wastes energy defending the
indefensible people's energy bills are
rocketing
labor has a plan to deal with it axe v8
for everyone provide extra support for
the hardest hit and pay for it with a
one-off tax on oil and gas companies a
serious plan for a serious problem
what's the government offering
nothing
too distracted by their own chaos to do
their job
while labor was setting out plans to
heat homes he was buying a fridge to
keep the party wine chilled
while we were setting out plans to keep
bills down he was planning parties and
while we were setting out plans to save
jobs in the steel industry he was he was
trying to save just one job
his own
doesn't the country deserve so much
better than this out of touch out of
control out of ideas and soon to be out
of office prime minister
i'll tell you what this government has
been doing to look after the people in
this country throughout this pandemic
and and beyond uh we have been cutting
the cost of living helping them with the
living wage we've been we've been
raising uh we've been raped we've been
cutting taxes for people on low pay mr
speaker we've been increasing payments
uh for people suffering the costs of
fuel
can i just say to run in here
our constituents wants to hear
the questions and the answers the great
british public
the members of this united kingdom which
you're representing
they need to hear please let's see the
questions answers prime minister speaker
we will continue to look after people
throughout this pandemic and and beyond
but we've also mr speaker been cutting
crime by ten percent putting eleven
thousand more police officers already i
think record home building last year
more homes than at any time in the last
30 years we are building 40 new
hospitals which is bigger
think of it broadband has gone up from
nine percent coverage in our country to
65 already and as i said already i think
three times or four times today we have
more people more employees on the
payroll now than before the pandemic
began and uh and unemployment youth
unemployment at a record low mr speaker
when the history of this pandemic comes
to be written and the history of the
labour party comes to be written and
believe me they are history and will
remain history mr speaker
it will show it will show it will show
that we delivered while they dithered
and we
we vaccinated while they vacillated mr
speaker
and the reason we've been able to lift
restrictions faster than any other
country in europe and we have the most
open economy and the most open society
in europe mr speaker is thanks to the
booster rollout and thanks to the work
of staff up and down whitehall across
government throughout the nhs mr speaker
and i am intensely proud of what this
government has done
[Music]
you'll get more if you let the questions
come
not pause it
[Applause]
thank you mr speaker following on from
the excellent news on the economy and
jobs the prime minister will remember my
question to him last june about
proposals for a gigafactory in coventry
last week local councils granted outline
planning permission to create 6 000 new
skilled jobs to secure many thousands of
others inject 2.5 billion pounds into
our local economy and level up across
our region with fast rising demand for
greener and cleaner electric cars may i
ask him for his support to ensure the
swift delivery of this vitally important
project
i i thank my honorable friend for
campaigning for uh this wonderful
project and we are supporting the
electric vehicle industry we made
another 350 million pounds available
through the automotive transformation
fund on top of the half a billion pound
uh that we commitment that we've already
made in the in the ten point plan and uh
i know that uh the campaign for coventry
airport is an excellent one i look
forward to seeing how it develops
we now come to the leader of the smp in
blackfoot
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you mr speaker
this week
was supposed to be operation
save big dog
but it's quickly become
operation dogs
dinner the past few days
we've had more damaging revelations
about downing street rule making more
evidence that parliament has been misled
and an even longer list of ludicrous
absolutely ludicrous
excuses from the prime minister
first he claimed there were no parties
then he wasn't present
then he admitted he was at them
but he didn't know it was a party
and then mr speaker the latest sorry
excuse is really the most pathetic of
them all
nobody told me
nobody told me
nobody told the prime minister he was
breaking his own rules
absolutely pathetic
the prime minister
you know
what a loop the prime minister laughing
once again laughing at the british
public the prime minister is taking the
public first rules nobody
nobody believes him for the prime
minister finally take responsibility
resign
no mr speaker but i i thank him for his
question again and uh let me just let me
just remind him that uh there's a an
inquiry that is due to uh to conclude
i i believe he's wrong in what he
asserts mr speaker but we'll have to
wait and see what the uh what the
inquiry says uh but mr i think the most
important thing from from the point of
view of the uk government is that we're
coming out of uh the restrictions that
we've been in i'm delighted to see that
that's happening in scotland as well uh
and uh and that is very largely thanks
to the wonderful cooperation uh that we
continue to see across the whole of the
uk though you wouldn't believe it to
hear it from here in blackboard
mr speaker i'm afraid nobody is buying
this act anymore there ought to be some
respect and dignity from the prime
minister let's remind ourselves more
than 150 000 of our
and citizens partying he's laughing mr
speaker it simply isn't acceptable the
fake confession the endless excuses the
empty promises that it will be different
only if we give him one last chance this
is the prime minister who arrogantly
believes that he's above the rules a
prime minister who brazenly twists the
truth a prime minister
who simply isn't fit for office
the prime minister's former chief
adviser has said that he lied to
parliament breaking the ministerial code
prime minister a resignation offence
public trust is hemorrhaging with every
day that passes this tory government
loses even more credibility
when will the tory mps finally do the
right thing show the prime minister of
the door
mr speaker
i i thank the writer of gentleman but i
must say that i disagree with him and i
think that uh when you look at the the
levels of trust that the british people
and people in scotland wales northern
across the whole country have shown in
government uh that there the the single
biggest index mr speaker of that trust
has been their willingness to come
forward voluntarily voluntarily mr
speaker unlike many other countries in
the world uh to get vaccinated on a
scale uh not seen anywhere else in
europe and and that is because of our
ability uh to and the nhs ability to
persuade people that it's the right
thing it's a fantastic thing and by the
way mr speaker it's also a tribute to
the united kingdom because that vaccine
rollout was a uk effort
well
thank you mr speaker when it comes to
exporting as you're well aware file
punch is well above its weight and the
prime minister saw this when he visited
be systems fracture of the future in
lancashire last year in addition
fantastic local businesses such as
helical technologies tangerine holdings
and nature's aid are doing a great job
for flying the flag for lancashire
globally but i've also got many smaller
businesses who are eager to get
exporting into new markets what steps is
the prime minister taking to help file
businesses make the most of brexit and
maximize export potential
well i thank him for
championing i thank you for what he's
doing to champion trade with uh with
latin america and and i'm no doubt that
businesses small businesses such as a
squire hair uh are
are eager to get into uh those those new
markets and we will do everything that
we can to help and support him in his
efforts
thank you mr speaker
as the cost of living crisis deepens
this government's priorities get ever
more remote from my concordia encounter
with constituents
only this week i learned a veteran in my
constituency james scott took his own
life
as a result of
his struggle with mounting financial
pressures
this is a government who were found to
have acted unlawfully by the high court
over covert contracts and now preparing
to write off 4.3 billion allocated to
those coveted schemes why can the uk
government find billions of pounds for
profiteers and fraudsters but they can't
find compassion to treat the people with
dignity lifting the benefits cap and
reinstating the cut to universal credit
yeah
well first of all to speak i want to say
how sorry i am
for what he's had to say about james
scott and
this government does as much as we can
to support veterans and that's why we
published the veterans action plan uh
only only uh
the other day mr speaker but what we're
also doing is ensuring that we support
people throughout this crisis he
mentions and i i've said in my answer to
the to the right honourable gentleman
and many of the steps that we're taking
to protect people uh on on low incomes
and we will continue to do more mr
speaker he attacks the the uh contracts
for for ppe actually i think it was an
astonishing thing at great speed to be
able to uh give this country 17 billion
items a ppe thanks to the efforts of of
people across whitehall uh mr speaker
this country is now capable of producing
80 percent of our of our own ppe
[Applause]
[Music]
shortly before christmas my constituent
oliver freckleton was found at home
having been stabbed to death on the eve
of his 20th birthday
yesterday his heartbroken parents held
their son's funeral
oliver leaves behind a partner and a
baby daughter and two teenagers have
been arrested for his murder
now this tragic event leaves behind a
devastated family friends and a very
worried community
i'm grateful for the work that
staffordshire police is undertaking to
tackle violent crime in my constituency
and the extra 149 additional police
officers recruited is very welcome
but does the prime minister agree with
me that a multi-stakeholder approach is
vital to tackling crimes amongst our
young people and what can the government
do to support not just the police but
schools colleges and local authorities
in working to address this issue
my honorable friend first of all i'm i'm
i'm very sad to hear the news of uh of
the the loss of her constitution to
oliver and
like like so many uh victims of violent
crime uh the answer as as the case with
so many victims the answer is not just
policing that that is vitally important
and that's why we're investing so
massively in twenty thousand uh more
police officers and supporting them uh
with uh toughening the law mr speaker
but it's also as she rightly says
important to get uh all the institutions
of the state to work together schools
colleges uh social services uh and the
health service mental health service as
well
[Applause]
thank you very much mr speaker
why is it so hard for this prime
minister to admit that he made the rules
so he should know the rules and he
should follow the rules everyone out
there knows it's as simple as that and
if he had any shred of compassion for
all those out there who suffered through
this he'd go
mr speaker and i entirely uh understand
people's feelings and i i entirely
support what she says about uh obeying
the rules when you make the rules she's
she's completely right uh on on the
other hand i i do urge her i do uh
to wait as i said to the uh benches of
it to wait until next week
thank you mr speaker
you know the opposition to being told
there's going to be an inquiry they
versus every single question on one
issue well my constituents wants to get
on with other things
[Music]
in january 2021 the government estimated
that at least 800 million will be
released from the dormit assets game
extension did you agree with me that
funding through a new community wealth
fund will be a catalyst to level up the
most left-behind communities and the
bill should include specific provision
for a consultation on the scope shape
and nature of such a fund
mr speaker we
certainly are legislating to i thank you
very much and we will be legislating to
expand the dormant asset scheme
to include new financial assets which
would unlock an estimated 880 million
pounds uh we'll be considering how to
spend the english uh portion of that and
the community wealth fund that he
proposes is certainly an option and i
thank him very much peter grant
thank you mr speaker my constituent
annie has told me a friend saw the
ambulance outside the house on the night
aunt's husband died
she wasn't allowed to go into the house
to come to a friend
anne's husband invented his vest in an
almost empty building
while scores of his friends stood
freezing outside
and went home
to an empty house to grieve the rest of
the day alone
my considerate susan wasn't allowed to
go in an ambulance or even follow
ambulance blue light and all after her
husband had a heart attack other
constituents had the heartbreaking
realization they weren't allowed to go
into care homes to break the news in
person to their relatives that someone
else in the family had died mr speaker
in their words not mine in their words
the prime minister is a charlatan a
hypocrite and a liar what will he now
say to our constituents look i know
you're repeating what you're considered
i want more moderate and temperate
language promise to you might just want
to do with the general questions
certainly not there i thank you mr
speaker and i i want i want to repeat
that
i understand that the feelings that he
has relayed uh to me as i said i said
last week and i sympathize uh very
deeply with uh the the feelings i
understand uh why people feel as they do
and i i thank people very much for
everything they have done i recognize
the enormous sacrifice that people have
made
i apologize for misjudgments that uh may
be made in number 10 by me and anybody
else but please can i ask him to wait uh
for the inquiry to conclude
thank you mr speaker um i recently
attended a debate held by my honorable
friend for west aberdeenshire and
kinkardin seeking a central london
memorial
for the photographic reconnaissance unit
and in it i reference my northampton
south constituent mosquito pilot mr
george pritchard who is 98 next week
and is one of the last surviving members
of the unit
will the prime minister join my
honorable friend me and mr pritchard in
backing this fitting and needed memorial
i i thank him very much and
i will certainly uh do what i can to
support it though of course uh as he
knows at the memorial to george which
although as he knows this is a matter
for local authorities uh what this uh
house and what this government can
certainly do is ensure that our
memorials are not desecrated as they
have been across this country and make
sure that we support uh legislation uh
that penalizes those who indulge in such
desecration name diana johnson
thank you mr speaker mr speaker when a
prime minister is spending his time
trying to convince the great british
public that he's actually stupid
rather than dishonest isn't it time that
he goes now yeah yeah yeah
yeah
mr mr speaker i i think that was the
question for you uh rather than me but
i'm not i i look i
i i've made my point i think that the
british public uh have responded to what
this government has had to say in the
most eloquent way possible they have
beaten coded so far mr speaker they have
helped to defeat kovid so far mr speaker
with the steps they have taken uh by
getting vaccinated and implementing plan
b and i thank them
just for the prime minister for the
record
it's not speaker's questions mr robert
our armed forces
have earned the respect and admiration
of our nation not least during the
pandemic yeah on remembrance sunday we
commemorate their sacrifices but on
armed forces day on the 25th of june we
will celebrate all that is amazing about
the army navy and air force
in a normal year we get about 20 000
people at the event in scarborough but
this year we'll finally host after two
twice being postponed national armed
forces day
will the prime minister pull out all the
stops on land sea and air to make this
truly an event to remember
all right well mr speaker i have no
doubt that armed forces day will be
absolutely spectacular across the
country and that scarborough i will make
a terrific contribution and a notable uh
contribution as well
williams
thank you mr speaker last april i asked
the prime minister if he agreed with the
principle that politicians shouldn't lie
he replied that he concurred with the
basic principle that the honourable
gentleman has just pronunciated
would he like to amend the record
[Laughter]
no mr speaker
thank you mr speaker the the vast
majority of people and indeed
politicians across northern ireland
believe that whatever the question
double jobbing
is not the answer
could i urge my right honourable friend
to listen to the majority
and ask him not to move the government
amendment in the other place later
today i i'm grateful to my uh my
honourable friend and uh i'm i'm advised
that i think the amendment in question
is indeed going to be withdrawn
twist
mr speaker my constituents are rightly
angry at the prime minister's behaviour
but while downing street fights to save
his political life people across the
northeast are worrying about rising food
and energy bills
rising unemployment and rising levels of
child poverty
he talks about leveling up but my
constituents are seeing opportunities
cut
does the prime minister agree with me
that his government has failed and it's
time for him to go
[Applause]
no no mr speaker i really don't agree
with her and i i don't think she could
have been following anything that's
being said this afternoon uh we have we
have unemployment falling to near record
lows mr speaker and we are we have job
vacancies we have job vacancies at
record highs mr speaker that's what
conservative governments do they create
jobs and they get and they get the
economy moving
davis
thank you mr speaker
like many on these benches i've spent
weeks and months defending the prime
minister
against often angry constituents
i've reminded them of his success in
delivering brexit
but i expect my leaders
to shoulder the responsibility
for the actions they take
yesterday he did the opposite of that
so i'll remind him of a quotation
altogether too familiar to him of leo
amory to neville chamberlain you have
sat there too long for all the good you
have done in the name of god god
[Applause]
i must say to the right honourable
gentleman i don't know what he's talking
about
but uh what i think what i can tell him
i don't know what quotation he's
alluding to that he he's referring but
what i can tell him is that i and i
think i've told this house
repeatedly throughout this throughout
this pandemic i take full responsibility
for everything done in this government
and
throughout the pandemic
stephen
does the prime minister agree with the
leader of the house that the leader of
the scottish conservatives is a light
weight
mr speaker
the conservative the conservative uh
approach to the union is one that i
think is right for our country uh we
want to keep it together and i i and i
think conservatives in scotland do an
excellent job and and that's why
their dead stout defiance their stout
defense of the union was repaid at the
last election and labor mr speaker is
increasingly endangering our unionists
mr speaker and many people last week
welcomed the five year moratorium on
smart motorways however the m27 is due
to be open as a smart motorway in a
couple of months what reassurance can my
right on the phone give my constituents
immune valley and others in the rest of
south hampshire that the m27 will be
safe and give them confidence to use it
i i i thank you very much and i can
assure her that uh
we're well aware of the uh
risks associated with the smart motorway
scheme i know that my right wrong friend
the secretary for transport is looking
at it right now we now come to the prime
minister's kovid 19 statements i now
call the prime minister
mr speaker with permission i will make a
statement
on our progress against omicron prime
minister just like the let's let the
room clear and then
order can we please leave quickly and
quietly
[Music]
prime minister please
mr speaker with permission i'll make a
statement on our progress against
omicron and the review of our plan b
measures
within hours of learning from scientists
in south africa about the emergence of a
new coveted variant last november this
government acted introducing balanced
and proportionate restrictions at our
borders to slow the seeding of omicron
in our country
as we learned more about this highly
transmissible new variant we implemented
the plan b measures we had prepared
precisely in case our situation
deteriorated encouraging people to
change their behavior to slow the spread
of the virus and buying crucial time to
get boosters into arms we made the big
call to refocus our national health
service necessarily requiring the
difficult postponement of many other
appointments so that we could double the
speed of the booster program
and thanks to the extraordinary efforts
of our nhs and its volunteers we
delivered the fastest booster program in
europe reaching half our population
before any other european country with
more than 36 million boosters now in
arms across the uk including more than
90 percent 90
of all over 60s in england
and taking a balanced approach we
resisted calls from others to shut down
our country all over again
many nations across europe have endured
further winter lockdowns many have seen
hospitality curfews and nightclubs
closed capacity limits at sports
stadiums the return of social distancing
and in some places christmas and new
year as good as cancelled
but this government took a different
path
we kept england open and we supported
those businesses which faced reduced
demand because of the response to plan b
measures and while we must continue to
remain cautious the data are showing
that time and again this government got
the toughest decisions right
today's latest ons data show clearly
that infection levels are falling in
england and while there are some places
where cases are likely to continue
rising including in primary schools our
scientists believe it is likely that the
omicron wave has now peaked nationally
there remain of course significant
pressures on the nhs across our country
and especially in the northeast and
northwest
but hospital admissions which were
doubling every nine days just two weeks
ago have now stabilized with admissions
in london even falling and the numbers
in intensive care not only remain low
but are actually also falling
so this morning the cabinet concluded
that because of the extraordinary
booster campaign together with the way
the public have responded to the plan b
measures
we can return to plan a in england and
allow plan b regulations to expire
as a result from the start of thursday
next week mandatory certification will
end
organizations can of course choose to
use the nhs kobit pass voluntarily but
we will end the compulsory use of kovid
status certification in england
from now on the government is no longer
asking people to work from home
and people should now speak to their
employers about arrangements for
returning to the office and having
looked at the data carefully the cabinet
concluded
that once regulations lapse
the government will no longer
mandate the wearing of face masks
anywhere
[Applause]
mr speaker
[Music]
mr speaker from tomorrow
from tomorrow we will no longer require
face mastering classrooms
and the department for education will
shortly remove national guidance on
their use in communal areas
in the country at large we will continue
to suggest the use of face coverings in
enclosed or crowded spaces particularly
when you come into contact with people
you don't normally meet but
we will trust the judgment of the
british people
and no longer criminalize anyone who
chooses not to wear one
the government will also ease
restrictions further on visits to care
homes and my right honourable friend the
secretary of state for health and social
care will set out plans in the coming
days
mr speaker as we return to plan a the
house will know that some measures still
remain including those on self-isolation
in particular it is still a legal
requirement for those who have tested
positive for covid to self-isolate
on monday we reduce the isolation period
to five full days with two negative
tests and there will soon come a time
when we can remove the legal requirement
to self-isolate altogether just as we
don't place legal obligations on people
to isolate if they have flu
as covid becomes endemic we will need to
replace legal requirements with advice
and guidance urging people with the
virus to be careful and considerate of
others
the self-isolation regulations expire on
the 24th of march
at which point i very much expect not to
renew them
indeed
were the data to allow i would like to
seek a vote in this house to bring that
date forwards
in advance of that we will set out our
long-term strategy for living with
covid19 explaining how we hope and
intend to protect our liberty and avoid
restrictions in future by relying
instead on medical advances especially
the vaccines which have already saved so
many lives
but to make that possible we must all
remain cautious during these last weeks
of winter when there are still over 16
000 people in hospital in england alone
the pandemic is not over and mr speaker
make no mistake
omicron is not a mild disease for
everyone especially if you're not
vaccinated
just look at the numbers in intensive
care in other countries where
vaccination rates are far lower
indeed from our nhs data we know that
around 90 percent of people in intensive
care are not boosted so i urge members
across the house
to do everything possible to encourage
any remaining constituents who have not
done so to get boosted now
and for the next few weeks i encourage
everyone across the country to continue
with the behaviors that we know help to
keep everybody safe washing hands
letting fresh air in getting tested
self-isolating it positive and as i say
thinking about wearing a face covering
in crowded and enclosed settings mr
speaker
omicron tested us just as alpha and
delta did before
but let's remember some of what we've
achieved
we were the first nation
in the world to administer a vaccine
we were the fastest in europe to roll it
out
because outside the european medicines
agency this government made the big call
to pursue our own british procurement
strategy
rather than opting back into the eu
scheme as some people urged we created a
world-beating testing program the
largest in europe mr speaker and
procured the most antivirals of any
country in europe too because this
government made the big call to invest
early in lateral flow tests and in
cutting-edge drugs to protect the most
vulnerable
we've delivered the fastest booster
campaign in europe and we are the first
to emerge from the omicron wave
because the government made the big call
to focus on our nhs and to refocus our
activity and lead that campaign to get
boosted now that's why we've retained
the most open economy and society
anywhere across the european continent
and the fastest growing economy in the
g7 because we made that tough decision
to open up last summer when others said
that we shouldn't and to keep things
open over the winter when others wanted
them shut mr speaker this week the world
health organization said that while the
global situation remains challenging the
united kingdom can start to see the
light at the end of the tunnel and mr
speaker this is no accident of history
confronted by the nation's biggest
challenge since the second world war and
the worst pandemic since 1918 any
government would get some things wrong
but this government got the big things
right mr speaker and i commend this
statement to the house
here
thank you mr speaker and i thank the
prime minister for advanced site of his
statement
throughout the pandemic the british
public have made enormous sacrifices to
limit the spread of the virus staying at
home
social distancing and unlike the prime
minister cancelling parties
i would like to thank everybody who has
followed the rules i'd like to thank the
nhs staff and volunteers who've rolled
out the booster jab
the labour party does not want to see
restrictions in place any longer than
necessary
we will support the relaxation of plan b
as long as the science says that it is
safe
so can the prime minister share the
scientific evidence behind his decision
and reassure the public that he's acting
protect their health not just his job
the 438 deaths recorded yesterday are a
solemn reminder that this pandemic is
not over
we need to remain vigilant
learn the lessons from the government's
mistakes
with new variants highly likely we must
have a robust plan to live well with
covid
so where is it
he's too distracted to do the job
and it's not just the prime minister
who's letting us down
where's the health sector's plan to
prepare for another wave of infections
why isn't the chancellor working with
british manufacturers to shore up our
domestic supplies of tests
where is the foreign secretary's plan to
help vaccinate the world
they're all too busy plotting their
leadership campaigns to keep the public
safe
good luck while the conservative party
tear themselves apart
jostling for position
looking inward
the labour party is focused on the
national interest filling their void
we have a plan that the prime minister
doesn't
we would trade we would train and retain
a reserve army of volunteer vaccinators
we will build a supply of test kits made
in britain
to protect us from global shortages
we would raise sick pay and make all
workers eligible
keep schools open by improving
ventilation
break the endless cycle of new variants
by playing our part in vaccinating the
world
we would produce a roadmap for decision
making to ensure efficient action when
it's demanded we'd stop the
short-sighted sell-off of the uk's
vaccine manufacturing center
and we would never again allow our nhs
and social care service to be so run
down and underfunded understaffed and
overstretched as it has been over the
last decade of a tory government
mr speaker labour has a plan to live
well with kovid and secure our lives
livelihoods and liberties where's his
yeah
well mr speaker i'd be happy to share
the the scientific advice uh that on
which we've uh taken this decision of
course and and he's uh he's
he he can see it it's there for uh for
everybody to to consult but he asks
about our testing uh abilities mr
speaker we're conducting about 1.25
million tests a day we have the capital
we have the biggest capability to do
tests of any country in europe we've
built as i said as i promised the house
uh mr speaker he attacked me at the time
i said we have a world-beating testing
industry a massive diagnostics facility
which we never have before he attacks
that he attacks the government over uh
the distribution of vaccines to the rest
of the world we've already done uh 30
million we'll do a hundred million uh by
june mr speaker and a 2.5 billion 2.5
billion astrazeneca vaccines have been
distributed around the world thanks to
the deal the uk government did uh with
with astrazeneca so that those vaccines
are distributed at cost price he talks
about funding the nhs that party mr
speaker voted against the funding that
we're going to need to clear the kobe
backlogs and and fund our nhs mr speaker
throughout this pandemic he has been
absolutely shameless in veering from one
position uh to the next and he has been
he has been wrong he has been wrong
about virtually every single important
decision he was wrong about keeping
schools open mr speaker do you remember
he consistently refused to say that they
were safe because of what his pay
masters in the union were telling him uh
he was wrong about going forward uh from
lockdown in july on july the 19th he he
said it was reckless you remember mr
speaker he was totally wrong uh he was
wrong about the labour front bench were
wrong about uh going through uh
christmas and new year with plan b as we
did and they said we needed a they said
they said we needed a road map back to
lockdown he did that guy did oh wait it
was it was it was actually maybe it's
you that guy and they said they wanted a
road map back to lockdown uh mr speaker
at every st and above all mr speaker
they tried to undermine the vaccine task
force and to say and to say that they
just say that you could not spend money
they said you should not be spending 675
000 pounds of taxpayers money on
outreach to vaccine hesitant groups
that's their idea of priority spending
uh mr speaker
he has been uh you know it's been
absolutely miserable listening to the
opposite uh bench because they have had
nothing useful to say
[Music]
opportunistically uh from one position
to the other and mr speaker
did you did you get any idea from what
he said just now whether or not he
supports what we're doing
no
no
no
dude he does support it okay is he
bought okay he supports it this week mr
speaker but what you can be certain of
and what you can be certain of mr
speaker is that if he thinks if he
thinks if he thinks that there's any
political opportunity in opposing it
next week he won't hesitate to do so
he's been kept in hindsight throughout
mr speaker captain hindsight and he's
had absolutely nothing useful to say or
to contribute lisa may
thank you uh mr speaker i further housed
my entry in the members register
uh can i say to my right honourable
friend that many of my constituents work
in the aviation sector
i welcome the announcement he's made
about plan b restrictions today but i
note he made no reference to the tests
that are still required for people
coming into england
if we're going to learn to live with
kovid we need to facilitate travel so
will he take this opportunity to
announce that when plan b restrictions
are removed next week it will also the
government also make it clear that there
will be no test requirements for anybody
entering england who is fully vaccinated
i thank my right on reform we're
certainly reviewing the testing
arrangements for uh for travel and uh my
my run from secretary for health will be
uh making a statement uh in the next few
days on that mr speaker but i think it's
very important everybody in the country
understands that getting your booster uh
wherever you want to go in the world
getting your booster is going to be a
pretty crucial thing to do
we now come to him blackfoot
thank you mr speaker and i thank the
prime minister for advanced site of his
statement we're all grateful that the
data suggests that we've turned a corner
in the omicron wave and then the success
of the vaccination program in particular
gives us cause to be hopeful in the
months ahead
but though declining the level of
inflicted infection is still undoubtedly
high and the nhs remains under pressure
that is why caution is the key
rather than the pm strategy of throwing
caution to the wind
baseline measures of face coverings and
indoor public places and working for
home where possible which scotland still
has in place throughout are extremely
important in the weeks ahead
as is the guidance on lateral flow test
so will the prime minister guarantee and
maybe if he can come off his phone
because this is important so will the
prime minister guarantee that lateral
flow tests will remain free as they are
required and put to bed speculation that
they will be removed free at the point
of need
but mr speaker while the data gives us
cause to be optimistic
the real problem for the prime minister
is that
no matter what the data has said today
he had no choice but to throw caution to
the wind
the pathetic and unbelievable excuses
that he doesn't know his own rules have
left the prime minister weak
the prime minister
is unable to lead on this issue
or on any other
and the public can't trust a single word
that the prime minister says
any shred of credibility
has gone
in a global pandemic which is what the
world health organization is cautioning
is nowhere near over
and during which new variants are likely
to emerge
it is deeply concerning that we have a
prime minister like this at the hell who
simply is not fit to lead and even
though thankfully the figures give us
cause to be hopeful it's clear that the
prime minister cannot carry on when his
credibility has all gone uh prime
minister well mr speaker i repeat the
points i made earlier on uh to the to
the right honorable uh gentleman and uh
i think that the the whole effort the
reason we're in the the state that we
are uh is because of the immense
cooperation has been across the whole of
the of the uk he talks about uh testing
uh and of course we'll keep lateral flow
tests for us for as long as as is
necessary but testing has been a
fantastic example of union collaboration
i've seen for myself and tests been uh
done in uh been assessed in glasgow that
were coming from people uh in sussex
it's been an um i've seen the work of
the uk armed services uh helping people
across the whole of the uk to move
people uh who needed treatment uh to
wherever it has been a fantastic example
of union uh collaboration i hope he
bears that in mind yeah yeah absolutely
but now come to the tourist committee
jeremy
thank you mr speaker at the height of
the first wave this government had the
courage to pre-order 400 million doses
of vaccine without even knowing if they
work and that has laid the foundations
for us having the best vaccine program
of any large country so i welcome
today's announcement it won't surprise
the prime minister though if i draw his
attention to the fact that nhs doctors
and nurses are absolutely shattered
he will have seen this week that one in
six doctors
say that they have had near-misses or
harmed patients because of exhaustion so
if he doesn't want to accept the select
committee's recommendations to address
the workforce crisis what will he do to
give hope to our brilliant frontline
staff
first
mr speaker i want to and my right
honorable friend has a great deal of
expertise in this matt i want to thank
everybody in the nhs uh all staff uh
front line uh and all staff for what
they've been doing
and i know he's right of what he says
about how tired people are they are
they're they're exhausted uh mr speaker
but they're also working heroically and
doing an incredible job and uh it's
because there are seventeen thousand uh
covered cases that we as i said uh we've
got to remain cautious in spite of the
the what the general opposite was saying
i i we do we do need to remain cautious
and we need to make sure that we uh
continue to recruit for our amazing nhs
there is now 44 000 44 000 more
healthcare professionals mr speaker than
there were in 2020. that's as a result
of the recruitment by this government
yeah martial
thank you mr speaker we know that the
vaccine still remains one of the best
defenses against this virus but over the
past month we have seen a slowing in the
booster vaccination rate so can the
prime minister update the house as to
when he expects a completion date for
the booster vaccination but also
can he set out a plan as to how he is
going to encourage take up of the
vaccination among certain groups
particularly young people prime minister
she makes an incredibly important point
i'm grateful to her because there is a
job of work for all of us uh to do in
reaching out to uh to groups kurt to uh
who who and it's at the moment it's not
actually hesitancy it's more apathy
that's the problem it's because omicron
is is seen wrongly uh to be a mild
disease that people are not getting uh
the vaccine in the way that they uh they
might and we need we need to break down
that that apathy with those groups and
uh we're doing everything we can to do
that the numbers are rising the whole
time but we want them to rise faster i'm
drew that
thank you mr speaker you would think
that today of all days opposition
benches could be delighted for our great
united kingdom
delighted that legal restrictions could
come to an end soon delighted about the
amazing vaccine rollout and delighted
about the strength of our economy
all a superb team effort led by my right
honourable friend but what can he
reassure me
that in the work that looks post-fact
that he will very carefully assess the
lock down impact on people having babies
and in particular those who were
separated from their partners who were
unable to take part in the birth
experience with them which is so vital
for giving every baby the best start for
life prime minister
uh kai thank my right honourable friend
for what she has just said and her point
about uh birth partners being able to
attend uh is uh unbelievably important
and and i'm glad that we were able to uh
to address it in spite of some some
difficulties and her early start for
life program is is unbelievably uh
important and i i know that uh that uh
both my right or friend for uh for
education and for health and working
with her to deliver it
speaker yesterday the prime minister had
to accept that he was unaware of what
his own coveted rules actually allowed
with millions of british people now
seeing that the prime minister can't
even grasp what his own basic rules are
he's no longer a credible person to set
the rules for others during this public
health crisis
isn't it time he accepted that the house
and the country can no longer trust him
with the nation's health
and the best policy to beat covid now
will be for him to resign
mr speaker
as as
as we say
[Applause]
uh
uh mr speaker i i i don't agree with him
uh i want to to go on and deliver on the
people's priorities uh this government
was elected with a with an enormous
mandate to united level up across our
country and that is what we're going to
do
[Music]
thank you very much um mr speaker um i
hope the prime minister will forgive me
for not being extraordinarily grateful
for the withdrawal of these measures i i
and many colleagues on these benches
didn't think they were necessary in
december but i do nonetheless welcome
their removal can i draw his attention
to a further policy which i think it
would be helpful if he reconsidered
um the government's current plan is to
say to our valuable nhs staff that if
they refuse to be vaccinated they're to
be sacked
and those sackings are to commence in a
couple of weeks time with no
compensation
we know and we know now that the
secretary of state is being advised by
his own officials
due to the
lack of protection against transmission
that this needs to be rethought can i
urge the prime minister to rethink this
policy we shouldn't reward our nhs staff
all their dedication
with the sac we should allow them to
continue in the valuable work that they
deliver to our great country
i thank him very much and uh and i i
respect very much the the points of view
that he's put across consistently
throughout this uh throughout this
pandemic and it's very been very
important uh that we've had a voice uh
speaking up for for freedom in the way
that that he has but i have to think
also of those who will be at the bedside
of uh elderly and vulnerable people uh
who are dying of nosocomial
nosocomially acquired
covid and and their feelings about
our failure to uh get vaccination rates
up high enough within uh the nhs and
it's it's a very very uh grim uh
problems i'm sure he can uh he can
understand mr speaker and nobody wants
to have a compulsory vaccination but
since the uh policy was announced rates
of vaccination within the nhs have gone
up uh notably and that's a po that's a
positive thing uh we will reflect on uh
on the way ahead uh we don't want to
drive people out of the uh out of the
service but it is a professional
responsibility of everybody looking
after the health of others within our
nhs to get vaccinated and i hope he
agrees with that when david
does the prime minister agree with me
but unlike someone who attended bring
his bring your own booze parties
the world's first minister mark
drakeford has behaved with decency and
integrity throughout this entire
pandemic
it's certainly been uh uh i think i
think the collaboration across uh
england scott and wales northern ireland
has been exemplary and i i've i've
enjoyed uh working with uh with our
partners will continue to do so good
tips
very much uh mr speaker i refer on the
moments to be my entry in the register
and can i um thank the prime minister of
his statement today and particularly uh
the decision to now remove face masks
from schools
i know many children and staff peoples
and parents are extremely pleased that
that is that is now happening but i know
he will also share my concern and that's
of the children's commissioner dame
rachel de souza that during the pandemic
we've seen many thousands of children
who have become
off the radar of schools off school
roles
and particularly the most vulnerable
children this causes serious problems
about their exposure to
to crime and exploitation so will he
look again at some of the
recommendations in my review of school
exclusion to try and address this that
we can track every pupil who is of a
school age because we should have as a
basic principle
knowing that every child is in school
where they're in school and what their
future is to be
yeah
um mr speaker my honorable friend is an
expert in this and he's spot on in what
he says uh i i don't want to see
excluded kids uh being
you're locked in a cycle of ever growing
deprivation uh he's absolutely right the
best place for kids is in school that's
why we worked so hard uh to keep uh
schools open and to insist that they
were safe caroline lucas
thank you uh mr speaker i was listening
carefully to the prime minister's
statement i don't think he mentioned
long covered once yet according to the
ons over a million people are living
with this debilitating condition
yesterday the all party group on
coronavirus heard heartbreaking
testimony from frontline nhs workers who
are living with long covid um and many
of whom cannot return to work because of
this condition will he now commit to
formally recognizing long covid as an
occupational disease and launch a
compensation scheme for frontline
workers who are left unable to work
after catching covert whilst on the
front line of our pandemic response
prime minister i i thank and i i i
really understand the
concerns of people with with lanka
everybody knows people who've had an
experience with kobe that has gone on uh
far longer than uh than many others and
who've had a genuinely uh debilitating
time and uh we are looking at it uh the
uh the research continues and we will do
whatever we can to support people uh
with long cover but there's a there's a
deal of work still to be done let's have
the most exciting mom said desmond swing
can i welcome wholeheartedly the
announcements that have been made today
and
i would ask the prime minister to review
again the need to sack domiciliary
workers and nhs workers and to examine
that evidence that suggests that they
pose a risk to their statements when our
belief is that they won't any more than
unvaccinated
prime minister made your point on this
thing i i thank him very much but i i
think that
the evidence is clear that healthcare
professionals should get vaccinated
thank you mr speaker the rush to remove
the requirements for masks including on
public transport will cause people to
fall ill and die unnecessarily isn't
this
all about
saving the prime minister's political
skin not about protecting public health
what a moral failure and what a bad way
to go
minister well mr speaker mrs b i know
that he's at variance with his uh with
his front bench on that point uh not for
the first time i i don't think he's
right i think we should test to the
judgment of the rich people that's what
we're going to do
thank you mr speaker
i uh to want to welcome today's
statement and the review of the plan b
measures unlike colleagues here on this
side of the house i too want to
question on behalf of the 100 000 nhs
workers the mandatory vaccination given
the chief medical officer told mps that
vaccinations had a minimal impact on
transmission isn't it the case now there
is no reason at all for mandatory
vaccinations for care workers and nhs
staff over the last two years these
people have worked tirelessly on the
front line and we have clapped these key
workers can the prime minister now make
sure that he doesn't sack them it is
utterly unjustifiable prime minister i i
understand her
her point but i must say that the nhs
fully supports the policy because of uh
considered other considerations for for
patient safety and i i would just repeat
what i've said to several members i
really think it's the duty of health
care professionals to get vaccinated
i don't care
[Music]
after he called for the prime minister's
resignation over particularly the branch
manager of the scottish conservatives
which was referred to as a lightweight
by the leader of the house
i simply ask how does the prime minister
think he can maintain his position and
continue to issue rules and advice on
kobud when he can't follow the rules
himself at some point
mr speaker i don't agree with her with
greatest respect and uh she will have to
uh wait to see what whenever the inquiry
uh concludes uh but uh but but mr
speaker i think that the
work on uh rules and guidance which we
which you've done together with our
friends and partners in the scottish
administration has been exemplary and
it's helped this whole country uh to
come out of covid faster than any other
european country
siobhan bailey thank you mr speaker um i
welcome my honourable friend's statement
today specifically particularly about
masks and i hope they never ever return
in our schools
but sadly it felt to many of us that
were concerned about the plan b measures
that there was no learning from the last
two years and we've had the impact on
businesses including my beloved wedding
sector has been quite serious with fears
about the next winter already affecting
bookings will my right honourable friend
confirm that we're learning from facts
and not just models to give confidence
that our response to the next variant
because it will come will be assessed
accordingly
yes mr speaker and if she wants uh to
look at other european countries like
share her uh enthusiasm for the weddings
uh industry in business are
fantastically important uh there's this
uh a massive a massive employer in our
country uh but other european countries
i hesitate to make this point again mr
speaker have been in a far worse state
when it comes to the uh the
the closures and the restrictions
they've been forced to impose i'm i'm
thrilled that we've been able to open up
in the way uh that we have and uh get
people uh married in the style and uh
and problem that they want marie river
thank you mr speaker mr speaker
prime minister there is a group of
vulnerable people who are not able to
receive the booster they've enquired
through the ccgs the doctors and hs
england there is a blockage in the
system they've had three injections but
the third one doesn't count as a booster
and they were told they'd get the fourth
but they cannot access it please
intervene and get people talking to
unblock this
prime minister i thank her very much and
we're we're working fast to unblock it
so that the people get the fourth jab as
as fast as possible
david johnson
thank you mr speaker can i warmly
welcome my own girlfriend's statement
today can i ask him if he will not just
remove the work from home guidance but
actively encourage people to return to
the office
because it's not just good for the
economy it's particularly important for
younger workers who can't get the skills
experience and networks they need by
working from home prime minister yes
well mr speaker i do agree with that and
i think that uh actually across
whitehall we need to show a lead and
make sure that we get back to to work
everybody get gets back to work it is
safe to do so provided everybody
exercises the due caution uh that i've
set out today but i entirely agree uh
with my honourable friend
mitwick
thank you mr speaker
we are mercifully in a much better
position today than we were this time a
year ago and that's thanks to the heroic
efforts of the nhs and the
vaccinations but just nine percent of
people living in africa have been
vaccinated against covert 19 to date
does the prime minister agree with me
that the uk is failing to honor its
humanitarian applications to the poorest
countries in the world and will he
commit his government to support a
waiver of intellectual property rights
on court with 19 vaccines prime minister
i i i agree with him mr speaker about
the importance of vaccinating the world
no one's safety and everybody's safe
that's that is clear
and we must get more vaccines to uh to
africa in particular uh i've i've talked
to uh to to colleagues in uh in african
governments and african leaders uh about
what we can do to have more fill and
finish in africa what we can do to
encourage
africa's own supply
of vaccination that's the that's the
best long-term answer uh but uh what we
need to do in the meantime is donate uh
our vaccines which is what we're doing
the uk's donating 100 million as i told
the house earlier by by june but also uh
to continue the the roll out of the the
astrazeneca jab which don't forget uh is
basically has basically been
underwritten by the british state in the
sense that it is delivered at cost uh
thanks to the deal that we did that in
addition to the the 548 uh million
pounds that we've given uh to uh to
kovacs uh and the investment in in gavi
as well so the uk i think has a proud
record on vaccinating the world but
there is clearly much much more that the
world needs to do and i i agree with him
about that
welcome for the return to plan a from me
mr speaker i hope it is irreversible
this time now the prime minister knows
our young people have missed out on so
much and now they face punishment for
doing the right thing when it comes to
travel especially our teenagers they
cannot prove prime minister that they've
had two jobs on the nhs app if they're
under 16 because they can't access it
even if they can access sort of
cumbersome process involving a letter
from the nhs those with one jab and a
recent infection they cannot prove that
at all that effectively grounds them now
prime minister half term is coming
family memories are now and not at some
point in the future please can we
urgently with the health secretary
sitting next to him find a way that
teenagers are treated with fairness and
parity with their parents on these
important issues so they can get on with
their lives with their families
my honourable friend makes an extremely
important point about uh about young
people and
vaccination i do think that uh people
need to appreciate the value of
vaccination uh for ease of of travel
particularly uh boosters but it should
be as simple as possible uh for young
people i totally agree with him about
that and i know that my right honourable
friend will make your statement in the
next few days about what we propose to
do ely
well there you have it prime minister's
questions and an announcement on the
ending of plan b by the prime minister a
pretty brutal prime minister's questions
bookended by the defection of a
conservative mp to the labour side at
the beginning and a call from david
davis on his own side
to resign at the end let's take you
through all the details of what has just
happened while there was fierce
criticism
of the prime minister earlier the words
disgraceful and incapable were used to
describe him by an mp who was
conservative but is now defected to the
labour party christian wakeford the mp
for berry south made his switch official
just moments before the prime minister
fought for his political life at pmqs
this morning around a dozen mps
submitted letters of no confidence in
him as boris johnson's premiership hangs
in the balance
[Applause]
well that was uh just ahead of midday
and christian wakeford being welcomed
onto the commons into the commons and
onto the labour benches with applause
from his new labour colleagues as he
took his seat on the opposition benches
just behind the party leader in a
departing letter to the prime minister
he said
i have wrestled with my conscience for
many months and you will know that i
have made my policy misgivings clear on
many occasions in private and sometimes
in public
i can no longer support a government
that has shown itself consistently out
of touch with the hard-working people of
barrie south and the country as a whole
he then goes on
continuing my decision is about much
more than your leadership and the
disgraceful way you have conducted
yourself in recent weeks
however i don't believe all politicians
are the same and i do believe in the
power of politics to be a force for good
well the labour leader shakir stamina
used the beginning of pmqs to welcome
his new recruit
can i start by warmly welcoming the
honourable member for berry south
and to the parliamentary labour party
mr speaker like so many people up and
down the country he has concluded that
the prime minister the conservative
party have shown themselves incapable of
offering the leadership and government
this country deserves
well in a series of fierce exchanges in
the commons boris johnson attempted to
brush off criticism from his labour
party over his comments to our political
editor beth rigby that nobody told him
that the downing street party in may
2020 was a rule-breaking event
first he said there were no parties then
the video landed blowing that defense
out the water
next he said he was sick and furious
when he found out about the parties
until it turned out that he himself was
at the downing street garden party
then last week last week he said he
didn't realize he was at a party and
surprise surprise no one believed him
so this week he's got a new defense
nobody warned me that it was against the
rules that's it
nobody told him
since the prime minister wrote the walls
why on earth does he think this new
defense is going to work for him well mr
speaker if we'd listen to the right
honourable gentleman about about kobe
restrictions which is the substance of
his question uh then then mr speaker we
would still be uh we would have been in
lockdown after july
if we listen to if this is the truth if
we listen to the labor front bench in
the run-up to christmas and new year mr
speaker we would have stayed in uh
restrictions with huge damage to the
economy and it's because of the it's
because of the judgments that i've taken
that we have taken
in dynasty that we now have the fastest
growing economy in the g7 and
gdp mr speaker now back up above three
pandemic levels
well the former conservative minister
david davis said that he has spent weeks
defending the prime minister but now
it's time for him to go
like many on these benches i spent weeks
and months defending the prime minister
against often angry constituents
i've reminded them of his success in
delivering brexit
and many other things
but i expect my leaders
to shoulder the responsibility
for the actions they take
yesterday he did the opposite of that
so i'll remind him of a quotation
altogether too familiar to him of leo
amory to neville chamberlain you have
sat there too long for all the good you
have done in the name of god go
well let's bring in our political editor
beth rigby who is here um so david davis
they're really putting the booth in at
the end of prime minister's questions
and and when we saw that earlier
defection of course a relatively new
conservative mp his sentiment showed
that this is not just that the new red
wall mps that that the sentiment is
restricted to yeah absolutely
extraordinary uh prime minister's
questions look millions of people tuned
in last week across various news
channels to watch the prime minister
give an explanation of that party at
number 10 on may the 20th and today
people no doubt watching to see how he
would perform as these rumors now build
that there could be an imminent
confidence vote against him and i should
stress that no one really knows even
when
that threshold of 54 letters to trigger
a ballot will come
but that is the context in which he has
to perform
and i have to say he came into that
prime minister's questions today it
began with a defection
from a conservative mp and christian
wakeford is now being no doubt
criticized heavily by colleagues who
will be shocked and incensed by this
defection but he has been a tory
councillor since
2013 and was made became one and being
an mp in 2019 he crossed the floor to
the labour benches that is extremely
difficult for any prime minister
the labour party sources are telling me
that this is operation domino implying
that there's more to come now that might
not be true that might just be spin but
let's see
the whips can't be sure
and then it ended with david davis a
former cabinet minister one of the
biggest figures on the benches of the
party a former leadership contender
saying to the prime minister to his face
it's time for you
to go the first person to do that to his
face
and the fact it was david davies well
that is just
extremely extremely damaging for the
prime minister and i think both of those
events in pmq's despite the prime
minister's pretty strong performance
actually getting some of his mojo back
uh coming out fighting that really
speaks to the precariousness
of the position he now finds himself
because his demeanor was very different
to the interview that you carried out
with him yesterday where you know his
expression was very hang dog and and he
appeared very contrite um and
embarrassed almost
in the comments today he sort of had
some of that bravado back didn't he yeah
and i think look uh yesterday it was the
first time he had spoken in nearly a
week the revelations about um what
happened around prince philip's funeral
had come out and he hadn't spoken
publicly about that he was clearly
distraught actually about those parties
in number 10 the night before the queen
laid to rest prince philip extremely
difficult for him for obvious reasons
and he hadn't spoken about these dominic
commons allegations that he knew about
this event
on may the 20th this thing that he
thought was a work event but quite
evidently looked like a social gathering
with
booze and food and and you know dozens
of people there so they were difficult
questions for him to answer but you're
right he was very downbeat downcast
apologetic
humble
and he looked a bit beaten yesterday now
that didn't go down well with the party
either if you're if you're already
wondering whether he's the guy that can
lead you into the next election and he
goes out to face the country completely
defeated you are going to
that's only going to exacerbate your
concerns and so it was interesting today
everyone was waiting how will he perform
at prime minister's questions he
definitely came back
in the kind of form that we're more used
to him
being in the question is jane
whether
the view has coalesced in the party that
really he is done and whether he's done
in the next week two weeks few months
whether he can survive in the immediate
term can he ever recover and you saw two
verdicts there one from a very senior
conservative that has been in the party
for many many years and one from one of
the new uh 2019
19 intake which will
really cause worry in number 10 i'm sure
well what will this afternoon bring we
shall see beth thank you very much
well let's just take a look at the
details of how if there was a leadership
contest it could be triggered and this
is all about letters 54 out of 359
conservative mps that's 15
would have to write to the chair of the
back bench 1922 committee that is sir
graham brady now that would then trigger
a vote of no confidence if that happens
if just over 50 percent or 180 mps vote
against boris johnson he'll be removed
from office with immediate effect
now if the prime minister wins with less
than 50 voting against him he stays in
the job and he has the right to remain
there
unchallenged for a year
well this morning sky news understands
that around 12 of 20 tory mps who are
elected in 2019 and part of the
so-called pork pie plot have already
submitted their letters
and we know six other mps have already
publicly called for boris johnson to go
and seven if you include david davis
just there but it's thought that many
more letters have officially gone in
and as you've been hearing one mp known
to have sent the letter christian
wakeford has now defected to the labour
party well let's go live to the lobby
and our deputy political editor sam
coats and sam uh we knew about christian
wakeford just before prime minister's
questions
i don't imagine anybody knew what david
davis was going to do necessarily what
has been the reaction as mps come out of
that chamber
well jane welcome back to central lobby
one week on uh after yet another
difficult prime minister's questions for
boris johnson yet another set of uh
reactions from tory mps the difference
between this week and last week is that
this week there is something more of an
operation to shore up boris johnson
after the double blow of prime
minister's questions first as you say
christian wakeford very south mp he's
affected to labor and then the thing uh
that nobody saw coming which was david
davis calling on the prime minister for
the love of god to go david davis as
nadine doris once wrote on twitter xsas
is good at taking people out now those
two figures are on different sides of
the debate but there is an attempt right
now by downing street to get tory mps
out particularly on the airwaves to
start defending uh the prime minister
perhaps in a way that didn't happen
terribly quickly uh last week uh now one
of those uh mps is a 2019 joe anderson
wolverhampton uh southwest and he joins
me now stuart
troy mps look like they're voting with
their feet christian wait for now a tory
uh now a labour mp and you had those
comments from david davis himself a
former leadership contender what do you
make of it all well i don't think
christians thought this through his 29
intake same as me a friend of mine but
people voted in very south they voted
for a conservative mp under a boris
johnson government to get brexit done
level up the country and keep investing
in very south i believe at the next
election it will be back in the
conservative hands how did christian
wakeford end up coming to this decision
do you think he was ever truly an
integrated part of the conservative
party uh is he a one or four as
conservatives as well as labour sources
have told me there might be more well
they've not told me that i saw today in
a pmqs and i see in the tea rooms a
united
group of mps
2019 as we keep getting there called the
the new intake they're not all rebels
they're not all looking to do that we
have a united group of people that are
behind the pm and we're there to back
him um united up to a point lord copper
i mean we've got maybe a dozen putting
in letters calling for votes of no
confidence in boris johnson just today
you can't call them uh united uh with
any fairness do you understand why your
colleagues have been driven
to such a degree of anger about the
prime minister so i believe from the
2019 and 2019 intake there was only one
colleague which was christian wakefield
that had publicly declared he put a
letter in now that's gone now i get that
there's been a barrage of bad headlines
and it's not what anybody wants to do
everybody's here to represent their
constituents they want to keep doing the
best as i do for wolverhampton south
west we don't want to be in that
scenario we don't want to have people
defecting i don't know of any more i
hopefully there isn't any more but we
need to call unity get behind the pm and
just move forward on delivering for this
country as we have done so far but a lot
of your colleagues are very critical of
christian uh waif and suggest he was a
bad fit for the party he even apparently
had a nickname of christian wakeford
according to one of your colleagues is
it right to call him names after he's
gone well i'm not going to call him
names after he's gone uh it's his
decision is that was that his nickname
no i never heard that i didn't hear
about that he's actually his office was
very close to mine so i talked to him
talk to him regularly i'm aware he was
not happy on things but it's not right
i'm not calling him names i'm not going
to go and do that i wish him all the
best moving forward but he's not going
to be here long under
a kiestarma leadership people in bury
south voted for the prime minister
a week ago
the prime minister a lot of tory mps
were saying let's wait for the su grey
report we seem to have moved on from
that now we're getting the argument that
the prime minister delivered brexit
delivered a vaccine roll out he should
stay regardless of what the sue grey
report says is that right do you think
that nothing that the sue grey report
could do uh could say might mean that
the prime minister has to resign well i
think that'd be very uh naive approach
um you're aware of the ministerial code
as you've raised so many times and the
prime minister the same as every other
mp
every other minister is is bound by that
if it turns out he lied at the dispatch
box the prime minister would have to go
i'm not going to get into the
hypotheticals you're well aware of the
ministerial code and everybody should
adhere to that so let's see the outcome
of the report see what is said there but
at the moment we need to get behind the
prime minister we need to move forward
and i support the prime minister
when you watch boris johnson at the
dispatch box refusing to answer the
question when he first found out about
the party uh alleged party that he
attended back in may 2020. he just
refused to say when he was first told
about it and refused to say that he
didn't like the dispatch box did you
feel at all uncomfortable did he flinch
at those replies he could have very
easily answered those questions so
what we don't want to do is prejudice
any inquiry and he's been very clear
about that we need to see that result
and we need to move forward but at the
moment we need unity we need calm and we
need level heads to move forward
bickering or fighting or falling out
amongst yourself will not be the right
way forward uh what about uh
figures in your party who are holding
meetings about ousting the prime
minister what's your message to them
today well as i said yesterday i went
out and basically said we need to come
together let's get a level head and
let's move forward united if we're
divided as a party it will not be good
for us the outcome is not good do you
think boris johnson always tells the
truth
i think that the pm has been uh straight
and honest with us in the chamber he's
been there and he's delivered and said
what he means we need to now see that
inquiry we need to move forward and mps
are behind him uh there's okay you've
said there's been a small group that
have been holding meetings i don't know
the details of that but i know the bulk
of the tea room and in the chamber were
right behind the prime minister you can
answer with a straight yes do you think
boris johnson always tells the truth yes
i do thank you very much indeed so there
we have it tory mps now having to go to
the barricades to defend boris johnson
at this very tricky time those that
choose team boris are going to have to
continue to defend him for quite some
time to come because you've got the
sugray report you've got the possibility
that there might be other revelations
after that and who knows what's going to
come down the tracks in the next few
weeks and months with local elections in
may and then we go on as we come out of
the pandemic and face a cost of living
crisis it's a very tricky time for the
conservative party
certainly is sam sam coates thanks very
much well of course just after prime
minister's questions boris johnson
outlined changes to england's covert
restrictions let's hear what he had to
say about that
this morning the cabinet concluded that
because of the extraordinary booster
campaign together with the way the
public have responded to the plan b
measures
we can return to plan a in england and
allow plan b regulations to expire
as a result from the start of thursday
next week mandatory certification will
end
organizations can of course choose to
use the nhs kobe pass voluntarily but we
will end the compulsory use of covered
status certification in england
from now on the government is no longer
asking people to work from home
and people should now speak to their
employers about arrangements for
returning to the office and having
looked at the data carefully the cabinet
concluded
that once regulations lapse
the government will no longer mandate
the wearing of face masks anywhere
from tomorrow we will no longer require
face mastering
classrooms and the department
and the department for education will
shortly remove national guidance on
their use in communal areas
so as you just heard the wearing of
masks
will no longer be mandatory in shops and
on public transport with the public
urged to make their own judgment
guidance to working from home is being
removed allowing people to go back to
offices
and the requirement of showing nhs
covert passes a negative test or a proof
of full vaccination will stop in all
settings
anyone who tests positive will still
have to self-isolate until march the
24th that the prime minister has
confirmed
that the experts are not going to renew
current regulations if the data allows
let's talk to our science correspondent
thomas more not sure that entirely made
sense there thomas and so this is the
third time restrictions have been
relaxed what is the science that the
prime minister is basing this on
well he's taken heart from the the
latest data from the office for national
statistics which does show that there's
been a 20
drop in infections uh last week compared
to the week before now we've seen that
on the daily dashboard for some time
there have been doubts over whether that
was a real thing whether the changes to
the pcr testing rules uh might be a
factor there but this confirms it and i
think that has given him the confidence
that he can remove uh plan b
without leading to a big rise in
infections scientists aren't so sure
though we had warnings from the sage
group who advised the government
last week
in which they said that there could be
rebound in cases if the peak hasn't
passed in all regions now in the
midlands hospital admissions have
plateaued they're not falling as they
are elsewhere so there's some element of
doubt there about whether uh what the
impact this will have and there's also
been warnings from the university of
warwick they looked at the impact of
removing plan b and if people went back
to their normal behavior over the
following four weeks they believed that
there could be a rise
in hospital admissions between 1 000 and
2 000 a day
in a second wave in the spring so we're
not out of the woods yet infections are
still really high you know it's it's
about 100 000 cases a day the the seven
day average and that is much higher than
january last year if you think back to
the peak of of last year when they were
about 61 000 a day and we thought that
was bad so we're not out of the woods
this is a gamble from the government
they believe they can do it and they've
been proved right before christmas they
didn't go as far